This video is made possible by brilliant.
You're going to learn more about brilliant later in today's video,
but if you'd like to learn more about them right now,
go to brilliance.org forward slash biographics you'll also find a link in the
description below.
Friedrich Nietzsche was a 19th century philosopher who was most remembered for
his killer quotes and incredibly large mustache.
The main goal of his work was aims to uncover the fact that there is new
universal truth and there's the human condition is in a constant state of
overcoming our animalistic urges.
He came up with many amazing quotes that we still use to this very day,
including what doesn't kill me,
makes me stronger and of course God is dead while he is often misunderstood and
his work has been used for the justification of evil over the past hundred
years.
The philosophy of Friedrich Nature truly hasn't changed the way that people in
the 21st century live.
And today in the video we're going to talk about his life,
his philosophy and his legacy.
Friedrich Nietzsche was born on October the 15th 18 at 44 in Saxony,
Prussia,
which is now a part of modern day Germany.
He just happened to be born on the same day as King Friedrich Ville Helm of the
fourth,
which is why his parents decided to name them after their ruler.
He grew up in a very strict Protestant family.
His father was a priest and his grandfather published books defending
Lutheranism.
His father contracted and excrutiatingly painful brain disease.
That lasted for a full year before he finally died.
Then in 1949 Friedrichs younger brother Ludovic vague also died when he was only
two years old.
By the time you started going to kindergarten,
nature had seen so much death and suffering in his young life.
This he was already a very serious person.
He was near sighted and he got constant headaches from a condition called
Myopia.
Therefore,
he started wearing glasses as young trials.
He looks and it's acted like a tiny professor who was following too grown up for
childish games.
Obviously it's going to make it very popular with his classmates since he did
not make many friends.
Most of his childhood was spent surrounded by women,
his mother,
these grands mother rinse to once they all shared in the responsibilities of
raising him.
In 1856 Friedrich Nietzsche,
his sister Elizabeth and his mother moved to their own house in [inaudible],
Germany.
That house would become the place where he would write his most important work
and the property has been preserved to day as a museum.
They should have attended a Christian prep school and later transferred to a
boarding school.
He never got particularly good grades,
but his father had a state job before he passed away,
which meant that he got a full scholarship to any college of his choice.
Peep chose to study theology and philosophy at Bond University.
He originally wanted to become a priest like his father,
but after just two semesters he realized that his personal beliefs were in
direct conflict with the theological curriculum.
As he often got into arguments with his professors hands who eventually
transferred to the University of Leipzig and d started studying ancient
languages like Latin and Greek as student's need trip,
contracted syphilis from a prostitute at a brothel which made him physically
weekends in constant pain for the rest of his life.
Syphilis is also known for causing people to fall into madness,
which ultimately did happen to him,
but that's only there was no cure for syphilis today.
It's treated with penicillin bus that would not be invented until 1923
significantly after his death and he spends much of his free time listening to
live performances of orchestras and operas.
The music was so beautiful that it helped him to forget about his pain.
He was particularly fascinated by the work of composer Richard Wagner and Nancy
would pay you to see each new performance three or four times in a row.
He was completely inspired by the tragedy of the characters in Wagner's operas
and eventually got to meet the composer.
They became very good friends and Richard Wagner was sort of like a father
figure to Neat Jack when he was 24 years old.
He worked as a full fulltime professor of languages and the University of Basel.
He taught it for several years even though he claims that he was not all that
happy in the classroom.
He designed to to volunteer his time as an orderly at the hospital after school.
However,
he ended up contracting dysentery and diptheria from the patients.
There's health continued to decline so dramatically there's,
he would sometimes end up bedridden for several days straight.
He decided to retire from being a professor in his thirties and lived on a very
modest pension.
Me simply staying alive.
It was a constant battle.
He spent a great deal of time in bed with nothing to do and he was always
thinking about the meaning of life and humanity.
This is when he began to write books on philosophy.
Okay.
Friedrich Nietzsche believed that there is no absolute truth and the people
should not have a blind faith in their church or their political leaders.
Today.
This is kind of common sense,
but back in the 18 hundreds people were raised that there were absolute right
and wrong answers and there was nothing in between the wizard.
No gray by telling people to inquire rather than just blindly accept something
he inspired a future.
Generations do completely changed the way that we think.
One of his most famous quotes,
God is dead,
is used by atheists everywhere,
but it's actually misunderstood and rather taken out of context.
What he really said was,
God is dead.
Gold remains dead,
and we have killed him.
How should we comfort ourselves?
The murderers of all murderers?
He wasn't celebrating the death of God,
though he was making a statement.
The more and more people were losing faith all the time and he believed that
without Christianity,
mankind's didn't know how to figure out right and wrong without the existence of
religion.
People often looked up,
see their political leaders and royal families with a sort of God like
reverence.
He knew that people needed something else to take religions place.
He wants the people to embrace arts like music,
literature,
and theater instead.
Since he said that Shakespeare had just as much value to human morality as the
Bible without away people's ability to think for themselves.
He believed that the rules of society were developed to keep people down and to
maintain the status quo.
For example,
in Christianity,
it's taught that people should be like Jesus Christ and not have a desire for
material.
Things need should believe that this is only taught to the poor in order to
manipulate them to accept their station in life.
If people are taught to feel shame for feeling envious of others and desiring
more,
they may not try to achieve a higher status and therefore if they're happy with
it last,
they won't cause a revolution against their governments in order to demand more.
Nature tells us to embrace our own selfish desires and that the rules of society
as something that needs to be overcome in order to get to the real truth of our
lives need to believe that every individual passenger should be in the process
of Zelle.
Udo ving Dong,
well self overcoming.
If we are envious of someone else,
this is just a sign of what we really need in order to become our true selves.
For example,
if you feel envious of guys who look muscular,
it's a sign that you should go to the gym.
If you're jealous of someone who is rich,
you should find a job that makes more money,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Everyone has their own dream and if we refuse to acknowledge these desires were
only going to make ourselves miserable men's,
even if we fail to achieve these goals,
at least we have the satisfaction of knowing we tried.
Nisha said that if someone has succeeded in overcoming obstacles while also
accepting their failures with grace,
they have become an Uber.
Men Shore,
Superman.
He claims that every man should aspire to become like this.
He said the most people that stuck in between that animal instinct sends the rue
mentioned.
There is a constant struggle between the two impulses.
He was one of the first people to come up with the concepts.
That ignorance is bliss and then it's easy to be happy as a human if you just
accept the status quo.
He admits that the quest for knowledge and to become the Ubermensch mites make
him miserable along the way,
but it was a life that he chose to pursue.
And on the last many people have read of this concept of Uber mentioned,
misinterpreted it as to mean the ability to become someone who is superior to
the rest of humanity.
Others like the Nazis would see this as proof that certain races where more
civilized and therefore more human than others.
Now,
just before we get into just personal life and his death as well as his legacy,
I don't want to take a moment to thank the people who make this video possible
and that's brilliant.
Now I know midroll lands,
they're not great for the video here,
but these videos are long,
so I sure hope you appreciate it on a,
to have some sponsors in order to make them possible.
They're quite expensive to make.
Now,
brilliance a learning platform which teaches three something called active
learning.
Now,
like neat just said we should all question things and the best way to do that is
with a solid understanding of the principles of well anything.
And if you want to learn the principles of science and beyond,
then that's where brilliant comes in.
I don't know if you've ever sat down with you know,
some scientific textbook and going it,
you're reading it and then you ended up reading the same page six times over and
over again and you still don't really understand what on earth they're going on
about.
You're just not taking it in.
Well that's something that we'll passive learning and brilliant.
They're not about that at all.
Brilliant solves this problem with active learning.
They give you something super short to read.
It's usually just a few lines and then you immediately apply it to a problem.
So you really have to be engaged.
You just rinse and repeat that and suddenly through a few little problems you
are understanding stuff that you didn't think you would be.
I've used.
Brilliant and I think you should go try it out just to see how fascinating it is
at how quickly you can grasp a complex subjects you can support biographics.
They're going to brilliant.org forward slash buyer graphics and now let's get
back to nature
evenly.
Friedrich Nietzsche is a household name today.
His work would not be translated into other languages until the 1890s and by
that point he was already too sick to enjoy as new popularity.
So while his philosophy was well known in Germany,
he wasn't exactly it becoming rich and famous.
In fact,
his philosophy made him very unpopular and it ruined his friendship with Richard
Wagner.
Wagner indeed thought that Nisha had gone mad nature.
It decided to do isolate himself in the Swiss Alps where he could spend a lot of
time in nature.
The often wins on long walks,
thinking of nothing but philosophy only to go home and write his ideas down,
ready for his next book.
He wrote several volumes of as ideas and sometimes he got letters in the mail
from fellow philosophers and people who wanted to be as friends.
He met a psychoanalyst named Lou Andrea Salome when she read niches,
actually felt that his philosophy perfectly aligned with everything.
She had already been thinking.
She was only 20 years old at that time,
but nature considered her to be his protege.
Blue was also trying to challenge the norms of society by experimenting to see
if men and women can truly be friends without sex getting in the way of a
relationship in 1880 you need you to sign it to go on a year long vacation to
Italy with Lou,
Andrea Salome ans they're mutual friends.
Paul ree ree was also a philosopher.
The three friends wanted to buy an old monastery and start an academic commune
together so that they could live in a society there was only filled with other
likeminded intellectuals.
Friedrich Nietzsche.
He was excited since he hopes that he could finally have a group of friends who
understood him,
but his family,
they went totally against the idea.
Indeed,
his sister Elizabeth was always writing and letters telling him to stop trying
to make a cult.
There was also a bit of a love triangle going on because Friedrich can bull were
both in love with Lou and they were competing to win our heart.
Paul proposed to her first but she rejected him saying that she liked him enough
for them to live together but more like brother and sister.
She claimed that sex got in the way of thinking clearly and she used each his
own philosophy saying that society demands that women get married but she
personally wished to remain syllabus and to focus on our academic work.
Even though he agreed to be friends.
Friedrich Nietzsche was still only human and the more he got to know her,
the more he was falling in love.
After all,
blue seem to be the only woman on the planet who completely understood his
life's.
Everybody has a but she put them in the friend zone just like Paul [inaudible]
and had events.
Neesha did have syphilis and marrying him would have meant that she would have
contracted the disease as well,
but she continued to live with him flirting,
teasing and leading him on.
He remains hopeful that she would eventually come around and he proposed to her
two more times.
No amounts of intellectual reasoning could overcome his human desire and this
situation.
It became way too uncomfortable for the three of them.
His dream of starting a commune.
It never happens,
and Lou and Paul Roadway on their horse drawn carriage leaving Friedrich behind.
It's probably best that he got out of that situation though because she leads a
broke up with Paul Ryan's married a man named Friedrich Collin Dryas.
They apparently remained birth throughout the entire course of their marriage.
She actually did have sexual affairs though,
which is probably just a little bit hypocritical.
She also had an emotional affair with none other than the Sigmund Freud.
It turns out to this,
this was all one big experiment to heart and in 1910 she published a book of
cools,
the erotic wow.
We learned that she spends most of her life trying to analyze and document the
differences between men and women when it came to sex.
The relationship with Lou,
Andrea Salami,
completely traumatized.
Friedrich Nietzsche Mans,
he never got married.
He often wrote about love and how we can make the most logical person feel like
they going crazy instead of writing about his own life.
Though Beecher expressed his feelings in a book.
Gold thus spoke Zara through strap.
This is about a man who isolates himself in the mountains and finds all of the
wisdom in the world,
but he can't find any disciples to listen to or follow him.
He then becomes the loneliest man in the world.
Since he was rejecting Christianity,
Nisha knew that mankind needed some sort of moral compass to live by.
Therefore,
he wrote beyond good and evil and addressed all of the issues of what makes
something good or bad.
In 1888 he could feel his mind and his body betraying him.
His last book was called the antichrist where he expressed his trends,
valuation of all values,
where he was trying to come up with a set of rules for morality that could
replace Christianity.
He saw himself as a mater who was making a sacrifice for the human race in 1889
he was only 44 years old and he had a nervous breakdown.
He was triggered into hysteria when he was walking in the streets of,
initially he's ordered them beating a horse with a weapons.
He runs the horse.
How could it snack to protect it,
and he was sobbing and saying,
I understand you.
His landlord,
David Fino,
had to usher him out of the streets and get him back to his room.
He spent the next two days laying on a couch in a catatonic state,
so fino arranged for him to get him to Basel in Germany,
even though they'd had a falling out.
Richard Wagner and his wife,
they were still history friends.
They were the ones who got him help and he's got him into a mental hospital.
During one of the last moments where he was responsive,
he started to sketch a picture of a man and a woman hugging one another in a
long embrace before he slipped into a permanent catatonic state.
It was almost as if he was trying to say that all of his philosophical work was
nothing without to share it with an that at the end of his life love what was
the one thing?
This,
he truly wants it more than anything else.
Oh,
the oss,
there's only,
he was diagnosed with paralytic dementia,
which was a direct result of his battle with syphilis,
which had gone on for over 20 years.
Then many people also believe that the pressure he puts on himself to find the
answer to morality without God and to unravel the inner workings of the human
condition is what ultimately made him go crazy.
He slips into madness and was unresponsive when people tried to speak to him,
eventually died in the year 1900
so you know,
after his death,
Friedrich Nietzsche,
this work was being translated into multiple languages and dip again to inspire
people everywhere.
However many people would read his work and it's completely missing separate
what he was trying to say.
Even his sister Elizabeth,
who was a pseudo,
not see late at republished a second edition of his books.
She rewrote certain and sections of his work,
so you glorifying the German race as being superior to the rest of the world.
Because of this nature.
Has it been blamed for starting not just one,
but two world wars before world war one even priests were preaching niches,
philosophy at their pulpits,
relating it to their own countries.
This caused a great deal of national pride,
especially in Germany.
I don't fiddler,
he became a fan of nurturance.
He took this as a sign that the Germans were far more evolved than the rest of
the human race during the rise of the Third Reich.
In the 1930s fascists often quoted nature,
especially with his idea of the Uber Manch.
They wanted to make an entire race of superman assist welcomed out of Hitler to
the museum where they pose together for a photograph next to the bus to
Friedrich Nietzsche.
Even today,
many critics of niches work consider his books to be too dangerous for young
people to read.
Since his main philosophy is to question everything.
This can often manifest in acts of rebellion and teenagers.
After all,
if they question that teachers,
parents,
and governments,
they are more likely to lash out.
Indeed.
In 1924 this happened in the case of Leopold and Loeb,
they were two college students in Chicago who thought they were smarter than
everyone else and that they were the example of the Uber Manch that nature was
writing about.
They believe that they could commit the perfect crime,
so they murdered a 14 year old boy.
That defense lawyer at science in nature is the reason why they committed the
murder.
And yes,
it's a ridiculous excuse because plenty of people read nature and they don't
become serial killers,
but the jury,
they bought it and those two young men got away with murder because the jury
considered nitrous philosophy to be just that dangerous dislike.
Just criticisms.
Civilization of the 20th and 21st century has been completely changed by nitrous
teachings and did they continue to change things to this very day.
Now it's very normal to think critically and question the world around us and
it's often the basis of a liberal arts education.
As for those of us who do not go to church,
we tend to learn about right and wrong from what we see on TV and in the movies,
whether we realize it or not,
we are living in a very niche or ask wells.
It's just a shame that he didn't live to see it.
So I really hope you enjoyed video.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below.
Also,
don't forget to subscribe to this channel and check out and brilliance link
below,
and as always,
thank you for watching.